all right so we've lady on ville soon to
be leaving the Pittsburgh Steelers maybe
for the Oakland Raiders and Antonio
Brown soon to be traded to the Raiders
the Steelers have no Super Bowl wins no
Super Bowl appearances to show for the
lady on Bell Antonio Brown era in
Pittsburgh and that is inspired today's
draft now this one's gonna be kind of
open-ended and it's also gonna be
subject to interpretation we are looking
at the best teammate combinations that
failed to win a Super Bowl so if you're
going to get creative you got to make
your case Chris because this one this
one could get off the rails but here's
hoping that it won't well
well start the process of going off the
rails with rock-paper-scissors although
we may go back to the coin toss we've
said over the weekend I forgot why
because let's do it is it raised
everything locked and loaded for the
coin toss Kristen alright go ahead
alright call it let's go tails then good
old tails Oh baby
flexibility in the control room and and
not only did Kristen call it up
instantly she rigged it instantly - so
congratulations you get the first pick
yeah well I think the first one that I'm
going to go with is it was a special
trio I mean you could say what you want
but I know two out of the three of the
Hall of Famers I'm gonna go with the
Buffalo Bills trio that never won a
Super Ball and Jim Kelly Thurman Thomas
and Andre Reed I mean hey come on the
KGUN and what they were doing at the
time that was a special special team and
offense and certainly special players at
you know the three most or three skilled
positions on the offensive side of the
ball Thurman Thomas was ahead of his
time as far as that dual-threat running
back right a guy who could run the ball
between the tackles but was phenomenal
out of the backfield in the past game
Andre Reed could do whatever I do
everything he could beat you over the
top for bombs he could work the middle
of the field then of course Jim Kelly is
a Hall of Fame quarterback who certainly
could could do it all within the pocket
as a pocket passing quarterback good
decisions big-time throws tough as hell
so for me that's the that's the the big
one that jumps out to me right off the
bat yeah and and this
is one of those days where it's
unfortunate the coin toss is rigged you
you led me right into it cuz I'm not win
rock paper scissors because that's the
obvious choice for straight Super Bowl
appearances no Super Bowl wins all
hall-of-famers the Kagan reads I forgot
him I there he was in yeah I'm a dummy
sorry go ahead
yeah well we already knew that you
didn't have to remind we'll take it okay
there there are plenty of different ways
this can go now I am gonna start with
Dan Marino and the Marx Brothers who
from the mid eighties Mark Clayton Marc
duper Dan Marino and remember Marino got
there in his second NFL season he
assumed he'd be back at the Super Bowl
multiple times after that and he never
even got back to the Super Bowl and it
just felt like that was a group that
that was an offense at a time when
offense was really taking over in the
NFL
it just felt inevitable they were gonna
win a Super Bowl and they never did
Marino and the Marx Brothers my second
choice after you stole the best one yes
good thank you yes but that certainly
was a phenomenal group I mean a lot like
the the group I just talked about I mean
they were offensively ahead of their
time right that Miami Dolphins offense
and those guys you know duper and
Clayton and Dan Marino I mean they were
the the greatest show on turf that we
had seen to that point I mean come on I
mean Dan Marino threw for 5,000 yards in
1984 that'd be like somebody thrown for
over six thousand yards in this day and
age in the NFL in a single season that's
how crazy that was at that time so
pretty cool can't fault you there that
record that record stood for like 25
years
I know it's unreal and and and stood you
know for a good amount of time where the
rules had been changed for the offense
of you know side of the ball and quarter
backs and wide receivers to where it
still was not an easy task to pass that
up so my next pick I'm gonna go with one
that hits home to old Mike Florio okay
the old Minnesota Vikings remember that
1998 team Mike that went 15 and one with
Cunningham Moss Carter I don't know
that was one of the best teams I ever
saw not get to the Super Bowl
okay I mean men did they mess that up
who was that that put the dagger in your
heart that day was that Morten Andersen
who ended it for you for the Elena
Falcon Oh Gary Gary Andersen missed his
only kick of the year a 39 yarder from
the left left hash mark every time a
field goal kicker lines up for a 39 yard
field goal from the last left hash mark
I think of this going wide
the only kicking missed all year would
have put the Vikings up by 10 would have
guaranteed the spot instead of ball 30
whatever it was 32 33 and of course they
would have lost to the Broncos anyway so
it wouldn't matter well I don't know
about all that but either way that team
was very talented and those three
players I mean come on Chris Carter's
all he does is catch ten touchdowns
Randy Moss his rookie year I mean really
was a guy that we had never quite seen a
specimen like Randy Moss until until
that year a guy went what he's that tall
and he can run by everybody and make
people miss in space and you know Moss
everybody and catch the jump balls and
Randall Cunningham you know with the
second breath of fresh air and his
career throw him bombs all over the
football field that is like one Super
Bowl I feel cheated at him I wanted to
see that Broncos Viking Super Bowl but
that was a phenomenal team capitalized
yeah sorry 98 lost in the NFC
Championship game in overtime 99 they
were leading the greatest show-offs on
turf at halftime lost that game like
49:37 because the Rams exploded in the
second half and then 2000 if if who was
the receiver Antonio Freeman the who did
what catch you take that who did what
catch he did what remember how Michaels
did what he did
take that away Vikings have the one seed
and the Giants have to go to Minnesota
and instead of the Vikings losing 41
nothing I was there that yeah that was a
it was a heck of a game to three years
they had their shot and it all fell
apart after that so thank you for no
problem man that NFC Championship game I
was out with the Giants - whoo that was
over in a hurry man you musta you didn't
even get a chance to cry on that one it
was over so quickly that is better than
having it last for three and a half hour
losing overtime because I was asleep by
halftime I just said the hell with it I
took a nap because it was 14 nothing
right out of the gate it was Troy ed was
at Troy Edwards he let the kickoff land
right in front of him he looked at it he
looked at it the Giants were covered
it's someone from 7 to nothin to 14
nothing but I'm not bitter all right
here's one here's one that you you're
it's gonna surprise you but it's it's
one of the guys you just mentioned later
in his career when he ended up with the
best offensive performance we've ever
seen from a receiver in a single season
along with Tom Brady and Wes Welker you
had Brady Welker Moss the 16 and OH
Patriots failed to deliver and we don't
think of the Patriots in terms of
futility because they got six Super Bowl
championships but that was the best team
we ever saw the best trio of quarterback
and receivers we ever saw between Welker
and moss and obviously Brady that
failure there they should have had a
Super Bowl ring to show fourth they
should have had a trophy to show for it
we just assumed everybody this passed
through New England the last twenty
years has a Super Bowl ring Moss doesn't
and Welker doesn't at least not from the
Patriots it's actually unbelievable when
you think about it that they never got
one either one of them I mean so close
of course that was an unbelievable game
by the New York Giants and that
defensive team but yeah it's just one of
those things when you think about it as
a topical level you just go hey man that
team that went 17 hurt you know what it
was 16 a know and did all those special
things it's just amazing I actually feel
bad for Wes Welker Mike I'm not even
gonna lie I mean first awesome as he was
all the good things he did for that
football team for the fact that yes you
know he didn't get to win a Super Bowl
that it does there's just a guy who
loves football
I know how much he does I hurt for him
almost on that in that capacity alright
my last one I couldn't I couldn't
remember whether or not Welker
eventually got a ring he didn't he was
with the Broncos when they got blown up
by the Seahawks and his last year in
Denver was the year before the Broncos
won Super Bowl 50 exactly right so I
mean he was cursed as far as that was
concerned okay I I don't know where I
want to go with this because I'm going
to go with the San Diego Chargers okay
they're not you know and before they
were the Los Angeles chargers
and the LaDainian Tomlinson Antonio
Gates and I'm not sure what quarterback
I want to throw in here yeah I mean if
you can't pick the quarterback how in
the world can you say this is the best
combination of teammates to not want to
say I'm gonna go with the one that hits
this subject heart I'm gonna go with
Drew Brees because people value him as a
higher up on the career all-time
rankings as far as the Philip Rivers but
man they were all on the same team
together 2004-2005 am I correct it might
have been 2003 as well I'm not totally
100% sure about that
but man when you look back about that
one of the greatest running backs of all
time LaDainian Tomlinson single-season
you know touchdown records being broke
in the conversation for that record
every year it seemed like during that
time period Antonio Gates special player
I mean Hall of Fame tight end he was
unstoppable especially at that point in
his career and then there was Drew Brees
where we all know what Drew Brees has
become but at that point he was not that
player and there were certainly
questions about him but yeah they
underperformed especially what was it
that 2005 team where you know people
were telling them this is the greatest
team in the history of the NFL not to
make the playoffs that was 2006 five
yeah five one five that was Brees last
year right yeah the greatest team so I
look back at that and go just from a
name standpoint that trio right there
the fact that they won nothing
substantial kind of rings out to me you
know I could go a lot of different and I
I'm I'm trying to be nice to you because
it's Monday and and we had fun last week
and this is your second week as a
full-time employee but how in the hell
can you pick a team for this and not
know which quarterback you're gonna put
in there that that shows you you
shouldn't have picked the charger if you
can't figure out which quarterback
completes this group of teammates that's
a problem well you could have gone
either one and I went with the one that
was even better than the one I was
thinking about it I just I think rivers
I think rivers makes more sense because
in 2006 there were fourteen and two okay
and that was the year LaDainian
Tomlinson we're talking about all trios
and Drew Brees is valued as a better
quarterback all time than Philip Rivers
so I put him in there be quiet pick
Jurgen secure stop stalling
get your pick out not trios it's
combinations that's where it's subject
to some interpretations I'm a level
above you I'll keep going all right well
I'm going with a quartet although the
trio was the best-known Allen Paige Jim
Marshall and Carl eller and this is
where I thought you were gonna throw
salt in the wound I didn't think you
were gonna go 98 I thought you were
gonna go back to the 70s when there were
four different editions of the Vikings
that made it to the Super Bowl and they
lost every time the purple people
leaders couldn't get it done in large
part because they weren't big enough to
withstand a withering rushing attack
that was always the key to beating the
Vikings in the in the Superbowl that's
why all those games are 23 7 and 24 3
and 16 6 they couldn't stop the run they
were too small Allen Paige weighed 220
pounds you just run right at those guys
and it's amazing me week in and week out
teams didn't do that as a way to stop
the Vikings that way it was a boring way
to win football games but that was
always the way to beat them in the Super
Bowl they were great as a pass rushing
unit they couldn't stop the run and they
definitely couldn't stop the run when it
mattered most and the purple people
eaters had no Super Bowl trophies to
show for four different trips to the
championship game man that's rough which
one what's Super Bowl were you most
heartbroken with as a kid which one was
the one you were like oh my gosh that
hurt which one was it
well not none of them because they were
never close the game that hurt me the
most was the the Hail Mary Drew Pearson
push off from 75 that's the one that
killed me that was horrible yeah that
was that was I mean and you look at it
this way if that's the the most
traumatic thing that happens to you as a
child it's a pretty damn good childhood
that was the most traumatic thing that
happened to me as a child oh that was
yeah you well hey we always knew but
their wine and your medium rare steaks
we always know you had a privileged life
so that's all good yeah yeah well we're
not gonna go down that rabbit hole just
now mr. laissez-faire all right my dad
didn't play in the NFL let's just leave
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports